It's the world's biggest luxury company,
valued at more than $400 billion
with some of the industry's
biggest names under its umbrella.
Dior, Louis Vuitton, Moët, Bulgari, Loewe, Tiffany,
It's definitely the
dominant luxury player.
Absolutely the leader of
the luxury goods industry.
Fashion, luxury hotels, media
outlets all under one roof.
Led by one of the world's richest people.
LVMH touched the $500 billion mark,
making it the first European
company to do that.
So how did a young
man's vision in the 80s
lead him to founding Europe's
most valuable company
and which of his five
children will succeed him?
The story of LVMH is
very interesting because
it's the story of this company,
but also the story of this man,
Bernard Arnault.
LVMH Moet Hennessy Louis Vuitton
has soared to become one of world's
most valuable publicly
traded companies,
dwarfing its rivals Hermes as well
as Kering - the company that owns
Gucci, Yves Saint Laurent
and Balenciaga.
The man behind this staggering
increase in value is Bernard Arnault.
He gained the moniker
"the wolf in a cashmere coat"
thanks to his high stakes
take no prisoners approach
that helped him win control
of more than 70 brands.
But beneath the tough
exterior was a leader with a vision.
Bernard Arnault set out to
build a luxury supergroup
that would maintain many
brands under one company.
The idea seemed foolish to
many in the industry in the 1980s.
How could one company
hold many competing brands?
And where would he find them all?
The first stepping stone of his business
history, I would say, was Christian Dior.
Christian Dior was a
gem that he spotted
that was part of a textile company
that was going bankrupt.
Bernard Arnault knew that
Dior had the potential
to become a brand that was
going to become globalized.
If you look at all the luxury groups
and specifically LVMH, there are ways
of strategically transforming
in the industry
and for LVMH, it was always about M&A
sometimes aggressive M&A.
There has been a huge
wave of brand acquisitions.
The idea being to build a
big group as fast as possible.
But the biggest and boldest of LVMH’s
acquisitions was American jeweler
Tiffany's in November 2019.
At almost $16 billion it remains the luxury industry's biggest takeover.
But it wasn't without
its share of drama.
LVMH has said here and there
that they were not particularly
interested in that asset.
So clearly this came out as a surprise.
So in 2020 Covid hits,
and basically people
are buying fewer luxury goods,
they cannot go to the stores,
they are stuck at home.
At some point that there was a lot
of tense and protracted negotiations.
They threatened to go to court
and in the end, they settled.
When it completed in 2021,
what we ended up with
was a $16 billion deal
something which was four times
anything we'd really seen in the industry
outside of LVMH.
But if we think about where
both companies were
For LVMH, with Tiffany
it really opened up the Asian market
more in its luxury division.
LVMH’s business strategy, together
with a budding middle class
and Asia's fast accumulation of wealth
through the 1990s and 2000s,
provided the prime conditions
for the company's rapid
growth and past successes.
What has happened in China
in the last 20 or 30 years
is you've had this increasingly large,
wealthy, middle or upper class
who have been engaged
in conspicuous consumption.
That's been good for luxury goods.
What's so strong about LVMH is that
you have a lot of economies of scale
because they have so many
brands, they're able to negotiate
better leases with landlords
when it comes to their store locations.
And they not only own
fashion or jewelry brands,
but they also own distributors
and that's very important because
Sephora will not be slashing prices
on Dior products because that
would be too destructive for the brand.
Desirability is something that
really keeps him awake at night.
He's got to strike the right balance
between selling a lot of these products
without cheapening their
perception in the eyes of the consumer.
In the last ten years, LVMH shares
hit an annual growth rate of about 20%.
But the uninhibited spending
on luxury goods
stands in stark contrast
to growing global inequality,
making an escalating class
struggle especially prominent
and propelling an
"Eat the Rich" narrative.
In April 2023, French protesters
stormed LVMH’s Paris headquarters
when President Macron tried to
raise the retirement age from 62 to 64.
That very same day, shares for the
company had reached a record high.
Luxury today is recreating, in a sense,
the idea of elites, the idea of masses,
the idea of a lifestyle that
everybody wants to share.
Headwinds from a global economic
downturn are also emerging.
This sector was priced for perfection.
Just one little cloud in the sky,
just one shadow on the board
can actually create this market rout.
Obviously, the consumer is key
to the big luxury brands,
and the consumer is sort of
reluctant to spend right now.
Potentially trading LVMH,
it makes some sense because there is
a reopening consumer driven trade,
although that's already fizzling,
it would seem.
LVMH is particularly exposed to political
and economic swings in Asia
with 37% of its revenue in
2022 generated from the region.
In May, billions were wiped out
when a slew of economic numbers pointed
pointed to a fading recovery in China,
largely credited for
driving the industry's rally.
The Chinese economy, the
economic recovery is sputtering.
You don't have any concerns
about China's slowdown
at the moment for luxury?
There were always
concerns for the world
and finally, our activities are
growing very well for many years.
So I am optimistic.
For all his optimism, one
unanswered question remains:
Who will lead LVMH
after Bernard Arnault,
now in his seventies, retires?
In this real life ‘Succession’ scenario,
the world is kept guessing
which of his five children
will take the reins
as they all assume bigger roles in LVMH.
Here's who's who in the Arnault clan.
There's the eldest, Delphine.
She's the head of LVMH’s second
biggest fashion brand, Christian Dior.
His second, Antoine, the most
public-facing executive
among the siblings, oversees
LVMH’s image and public relations.
From his second marriage, Bernard Arnault had three more children.
Alexandre is the head of products
and communication at Tiffany.
Frederic heads the watch
brand Tag Heuer
and the youngest, Jean,
is in charge of developing Louis Vuitton's watch catalog.
One of the interesting things
about the family
is that they make a point of
meeting once a month
at the LVMH headquarters here in Paris,
where they have lunches
and they discuss everything from
business to personal matters.
It's a nice relationship,
and working with your family
is very pleasant.
Now being the son in a
family such as mine, of course
is a great responsibility.
Even with this children
in leadership positions,
it doesn't look like Arnault
is ready to retire just yet.
In 2022, LVMH shareholders voted
to lift the age limit of the CEO,
i.e. of Bernard Arnault, from 75 to 80.
I feel that that's already
built into share price.
I think that the market overall
expects at some point he will go.
Versus some of the peers,
most of the peers,
LVMH is very well placed for succession.
Arnault, via his holding company Agache,
owns 48% of LVMH’s share capital
but has almost 64% of the voting rights.
The ownership structure
was tweaked in 2022
to ensure the Arnault family
retains its control over the luxury goods
conglomerate for the long term.
What I think is really important today
is that once you have your whole family
set up, trained to the business
and to the family house,
they stick together against the enemy.
anyone who's not part of the family
and who would like to have stakes
in the company.
The idea is to have a family community
that is going to stick together
to avoid any type of intrusion.